welcome to the edge with your boy Micah
Parsons live on Bleacher Report app and
let's get right into our game with the
judge I told y'all guys we're coming
Dallas Cowboys Nation is defense is for
Real everything's clicking for us right
now you know God willing let's just keep
it going baby we back man doomsday this
is New Generation defense yeah I've been
telling people we coming you know yeah
and I like how Prime did that and they
selling that but you know I'm just
letting people know we coming too and I
love what's going on down in Colorado
with Prime's doing so big jumps to OG
Prime you know who started this Dallas
defense off back in the day and we just
kind of making our way and Paving the
way now baby so let's get right into it
it was good to see the Cowboys Nation at
the opener I said I need y'all to come
out and show out and defend the land and
that's exactly what y'all did seeing
y'all run out into the stadium like that
man oh man that was special where I
couldn't believe y'all did that for us
bro that's how we set the standard
that's how we open it up baby and we had
to make sure we did what we had to do
for y'all we put on the show listen I
see a lot of hate going on with Cowboys
I don't know what's going on I don't
know why the haze going on saying we
haven't played nobody but once again
those was both playoff level teams Zach
Wilson was the same QB last year mixing
with a little bit of Mike White and guys
like that but uh Daniel Jones he was in
the playoffs last year upset the Vikings
went to the second round so we can't say
we didn't play anybody and like I said
we these are teams that we show called
said they upgraded you know
um you know I think the you know New
York Jets is a premier team and we can't
deny them bro
um they just be our great Buffalo team
last week and it was with the same guy
Zach Wilson Zach Wilson held them lead
to beat Josh Allen in the Buffalo Bills
which is which is a fantastic team so
how can we say we haven't played anybody
Daniel Jones and them just came back
down 21 on the Arizona Cardinals and
well you could say they don't have Kyler
Murray but without Kyler Murray I mean
there's still a team that was up you
know 21 points on the playoff team so
I'm all about uh what you have done
versus what you're seeing right now
um teams bounce back teams face
adversity and like I said winning
National Football League so every day it
could be any it could anyone could get
upset on any given day man if your team
don't show up and play a complete Game
guys it leaves teams to hang around and
play around that's one thing I would say
the Cowboys emphasized this year and
that's we don't want to play around with
guys no more we don't want to let guys
come back we want to bury them we want
to finish them we want to kill them we
want to hunt all game and we're going to
keep coming and that's what it's all
about baby so hey let's start this off
right here I guess I did swap jerseys
with my guy sauce Garner and let me tell
you why sauce is a premier Corner in
this NFL he came in Young and Hungry he
resembles I was saying he resembled me a
lot in terms of mindset uh what he wants
and what he wants to accomplish uh a big
Twitter guy too so you know I thought it
was a little crazy I deactivated his
Twitter a little bit but sometimes you
just gotta do that to lock in focus on
what you need to do no social media and
that's cool as to him at a young age he
knows what he wants and where he wants
to go so he said man I don't need this
bro I need to lock in on my team and
help my team get better and he's showing
true leadership as a young guy which is
also important and something I I wanted
to learn early on in my career so Kudos
the sauce and you know I wish nothing
the best for his career and I can't wait
to see him keep prospering keep making
all pros and pro bowls cause he's on his
way I want to see what people are saying
with the crawl there was something that
someone hinted towards me said we should
go towards the death crawl doomsday
death crawl but I need you guys feedback
I need you guys to feed me names so that
way we can start pushing out content
pushing out t-shirts of the lion crawl
because it is a real thing it's like
it's like I'm possessed like my
teammates laugh but I feel possessed
like I almost said if I die today I'd be
reincarnated to a lion it's just in me
like I feel it like I just want to
explode like I just ride like you know
uh a crazy thing that nobody knows
sometimes I go in a around a facility
just growling at people and people like
yo what is wrong I feel like I'm hungry
like I'm like sometimes I get the game
there I'm already starving they starve
me all week I just want to hunt you know
there was a little bit of media
clippings of me saying I was tackling a
quarterback in practice I was just so
eager and so hungry that that just had
to be the first victim you know we kind
of laughed about it and yes I'm not
supposed to do that and yes I am joking
I do not want to hurt my own quarterback
but sometimes I get two
Auntie myself you know what I'm saying
so
um it was a good game though it was a
good game though
um I almost had a touchdown I do feel I
have been robbed out of my touchdown I
thought that was a touchdown I think we
should change the rules a little bit on
what it means of contact I don't think
the offense alignment had no idea I had
the ball I think it should be initial
contact intent with contact and March
someone down
um
because he I my what was in my foot or
my leg had barely touched this and he
had no idea I had the ball so I believe
that should have been a touchdown he had
no meaningful way of tackling me you
know I think this needs to be talked
about in the league like look at it he
does he's still sitting down touching on
one of our linemen like come on guys
like this should be a touchdown you know
and it still was a great play and you
know Darwin's still a great player but I
think I just had the better play right
here but you could see like he come on
guys I need my touchdown NFL we have to
do something about this we can't keep
robbing people and these people need to
have intentions of tagging someone down
not just leg touching or grabbing
um and so forth
um
I would say
you know uh it was a funny week this
week uh preparing for the Jets because
you didn't know really how to prepare
for these guys like you know especially
with Roger's going down and we know how
amazing uh Roger's arm was so you know I
felt like uh Coach Q schemed up a way
for you know I think it was almost a way
where I couldn't be prepared I could
have been more prepared in terms of pass
rush you know it got to the point they
they was Triple timing me at practice
and I said what is going on here and you
know they trying to get me ready for the
game the anticipation I'm getting angry
but you know how much those things make
me so much better putting this in them
crazy situations
um even with the Run game I we we
emphasize on stopping a run
um coming down hill and forcing them to
pass and play our type of football and
uh I would say everything executed and
even heating up to you know some of the
some young early emotional outrage you
know and as a young guy when things
aren't going in your way you tend to get
very emotional you tend to say oh it's
the reason because of this listen briefs
I I get it bro you you are a great
running back and you'll continue to be a
great running back in the NFL and you'll
continue but let's not try to uh put it
on the touches and things like that bro
I think you're campaigning and you had a
hell of a game last week and things like
that but you know it's all about what's
going on I think uh we set the tone
earlier winning the line of scrimmage it
comes a lot to it uh more than just uh
him getting the ball I thought we
dominated a line of scrimmage on both
sides of the ball I think our offensive
line
uh they did a great job managing the
clock running the ball
um getting the ball out so we put them
into positions where they didn't want to
give away a lot of clock continue to run
game they had to get points to the board
and our offense was scoring so it kind
of took away their run effect and that's
just how the games go sometimes when uh
both sides of the bar clicking at a high
pace so I wouldn't say um it was
necessarily I don't think he could have
changed the the game outcome too far but
I definitely think he could have made a
bigger impact than uh you know 8 or 16
yards whatever they combine for uh with
the amount of cares he had and just to
continue this man I wish my guy Aaron
Rodgers a speedy recovery
um
uh part of me does think that we will
see Aaron Rodgers again uh this year the
guy who performed his surgery is the
best uh doctor in the world Dr Neil
electrosh
um but it's just going to see when we
see him who knows uh I think the Jets
will have to do a great job almost the
type of job that uh we had to face last
year when we lost that their defense has
to click on all cylinders
um offense just have to take away uh any
type of turnovers that can come their
way and just control the game
um we end up winning about four out of
five games when we lost Dak Prescott and
when Dad came back we started clicking
again but that's the type of
um
terms and teams that you know coach
Siler has to keep on to their guyses uh
they got to play very disciplined
football uh if we want to see Aaron
Rodgers again uh and if Aaron Rodgers
could come in by uh you know January and
February football and they have to carry
it away uh so that way he steps in he's
stepping in and giving them a chance to
win the Super Bowl and uh maybe maybe
face the Dallas Cowboys in Vegas then so
you know it's going to be cool to see
um and you know I don't think the Jets
should sign a free agent guy
um like I said I think we tend to move
on from guys too fast you know Zach he's
still learning
um and you know it people don't realize
that how hard it is to make it to the
NFL don't forget this is the one percent
and if you got drafted you already are
in the one percent and he was a top
three pick in the NFL draft so obviously
some tangibles something is there in him
uh I just think we have to do a better
job but you know boosting confidence I
think everyone needs someone to believe
in them uh at the end of the day I think
belief is what it's all about
um you know when I came in Dan Quinn he
told me he's like hey Mike
um and you know believe it or not I
didn't talk to Dan Quinn out one time in
pre-draft interviews and uh he kind of
uh and the guy who did draft me is in
Tampa right now uh coach Grant uh
coach Edwards and uh you know I just
think from the very beginning Dan spoke
to me as like hey Mike I don't need you
to be a guy I need you to be the guy and
I believe in you so I'm gonna throw this
at you to see how you react to it and I
just kind of think the Jets need to do
that same type of uh motivation of Zach
and say hey we're not going to limit the
game plan we're not going to do this
just because you're our quarterback
um you're our guy now and we're gonna
put the ball in your court and we need
you and expect you to deliver this and
see if Zach sets up to that challenge
versus you know they're giving him small
game plans because he's not Aaron
Rodgers Bijan is the real deal almost
200 yards rushing in your second game as
a rookie having guys fall over like are
we serious Bijon all right if you wanted
to wake everyone up now that's the
statement the Packers defense is a top
seven defense International Football
League and the fact that you were able
to do that man that's showing us a lot
that you're here and you're here to stay
and that actually brings up another
topic of just the fact that people think
that running backs shouldn't be a top 10
pick and should we invest in running
backs
um I would say now do you think they win
that game without Bijan Robinson
um people there was a lot of hate about
um Atlanta taking Kyle Pitts the year uh
a couple years back
um taking Kyle Pitts fourth pick um then
they took Drake long game now they just
took Bijan and the beat in the running
back conversation well
Bichon just showed y'all what he was
capable of and I think Jamir Gibbs is
snapping out too who was taken by the
Lions
um these guys are real dudes and I don't
think just because of your position that
doesn't mean you shouldn't be valued I
think every player in this league should
be valued about what they produce and
how you affect your team
um just like saquon Barkley man he he's
a guy that I feel like should be paid in
the manner of his value
um I think he asked that team in so many
different ways he's receptions running
the ball
um even schemes finding ways to make him
extraction to get other guys open
helping bringing his team back against
Arizona before the the sprained ankle
um get well soon brother but you know
you just showing your value and what you
bring to this team and we hope that you
reap the benefits of it not because of
you know what you produce but because of
who you are as a leader and how what you
do for the Giants organization
um he brings a lot to that team and I
don't think his position should overlook
him and any matter and you know and I
and I say that about a lot of positions
I think a lot of positions are
overlooked because it's not value in the
sense of how people look at it but I
look at guys like Darwin James he plays
safety but I mean he rushes he plays in
a box he tackles he covers he does it
all like and he should be more of a
higher even though he's the highest paid
safety
um it should be another position that
isn't overlooked it's that's not other
positions that's overlooked
um so I think we should appreciate these
guys and what they're doing because
these are things we haven't seen before
in the National Football League and even
there's a lot of talk with me that was
like what is it linebackers your
defensive man it doesn't matter I think
we should just appreciate guys who are
impacting the game that we love and
showing our hearts out and doing what
they uh do best and that's just
dominating so let's not start looking at
the fact of oh well he plays this
position and this position goes through
injuries or this position doesn't last
long why don't we pay these guys for
their greatness and what they're doing
for their team and if something happens
that's the game of football that's what
we all signed up freak accidents happen
injuries happen if no injuries happen
I'm pretty sure a lot of players that
aren't playing anymore will be in the
NFL like look at Bo Jackson I mean he's
one injury away from you know and he's
still arguably uh a great running back
but he's one injury away from being
could be or if not the best ever so
let's not look at those things it's
football man Frank accidents happen
y'all see it all the time so let's not
Overlook these
and then we're going to talk about Joe
burrow and the Bengals and him
reactivating his calf um you know it's
hard guys like we're not going to sit
here and act like adversity and teams
don't happen you know
um look at the Bengals last year they
started their season off oh and two why
are we panicking I think the Panic is
that you know Joe burrow might have
rushed back because he wanted to show uh
guys that you know he could do this and
he wanted to lead his team especially uh
with the contract and things like that
but the key in this situation is you're
not you don't want to win September
football okay you wouldn't win no uh
December and January football and that's
the last four games of the year ahead in
the playoffs how does your team look
um this team started off on two last
year and went into the AFC Championship
game last year so is there a reason to
panic no you still have Jamar chase you
still have t Higgins you still have
Tyler board and once Joe burrow gets
fully healthy you're going to have the
guy that you guys have been looking for
I see Joe okay so do not panic guys just
let Joe burrow get back to where he
needs to be when he's escaping the
pocket when he feels good he wants to
run on his calf again and he placed in a
ball where he wants to do uh people fail
to realize when Joe was extending plays
instead of taking sacks that's when he
was most dominant that's when he heard
the Chiefs the most that's when he was
the most dominant one he was doing so
let's not panic guys give Joe Bro time
to get back to himself get to where he
wants to go and things are going to
change and the AFC North you know the
Bengals are a top team I I don't think
that it should be overlooked this is a
team that won the AFC North back-to-back
times
um so let's not panic guys and when you
start off with two division Rivals as
your first two games that's also very
tough and he also win against a guy who
is a top five top six however you want a
candidate quarterback and that's Lamar
Jackson
um Lamar is the truth and he's coming to
tell y'all
um he's he's going to collect and earn
every dollar he was giving us off season
congratulations Lamar and he's letting
him putting a legal notice just starting
out uh with a great start so let's not
overlook this I think uh in his battles
and who Joe lost to he lost to a great
Cleveland team and who has DeShaun
Washington before all this stuff came
out and whatever
uh Deshawn was the top 10 quarterback
and now he faces another top 10
quarterback and loses by three in a
close battle uh and you know with the
cash so
let's not panic let's just focus on
getting him better and uh letting the
Bengals get better and learning from
their mistakes and not letting it
collect and growing them
um
and you know another thing is uh we saw
Geno Smith and the Lions last week
um another great matchup uh Gino he had
another it was what is it it was going
back and forth uh with the Soundbar uh
you know hold on I'm talking to America
Gino I don't know why they keep getting
you miked up brother but this is back to
back week time to give you a break bro
like come on bro let Gino give Gino a
break bro that was an intentional
grounding by the way which was a crazy
call
um and
you know it's kind of crazy that
Chauncey Gardner is telling the uh the
Detroit Lions to all wear ski masks that
kind of turned out to bite them after
watching the Seahawks wear blue ski
masks after their upsetting win and come
back so uh we might want to take away
them ski masks and just play football at
this point in time
um because that right there that I had
you gotta get your licked back for sure
um and my reaction to that is hey that's
how you go out and collect Karma baby
hey it's just same way
um uh Jamar Chase said with the elves
the same way they collecting them ski
masks that's what it's all about baby
competition and you know showing people
what's up and I think that was a big win
for the Seattle Seahawks after coming
off that upset uh loss to the Rams
um so hey congratulations Seahawks a way
to fight back bounce back because that's
what it's really all about speaking of
talking trash Tyreek Hill said the
Patriot fans have some of the worst fans
in the world
um I've only ever played the Patriots
one time in my career and even in New
England it was rough even the rest was
rough I I you know I think New England
has a long history of some very shaky
behavior in the NFL and it starts with
some of their fans I you know I and we
play New England in a couple weeks so is
going to be a good game but New
England's team we always got to keep our
eyes out for there's always something
shaky going to New England
um I don't agree or disagree I'm gonna
find out very soon in two weeks I don't
want to get these fans no reason to try
to you know do something spicy to me or
start provoking me I know how it goes on
the social media because I entertain it
all the time but you know we're just
going to keep it plain and simple Tyreek
Hill I see where you're coming from
though brother you're over you know I'm
saying and Tyreek please do never say
you're lying again
um just stick to the cheetah brother you
don't you don't want nothing to do with
this line work before we sidetracked
today I saw them comments brother please
stay away from the line and at least you
did say you were baby lion because to me
you'll be a cub brother and I'ma just
keep it real and you know the battle is
always back and forth between me and you
so I expect your response you're gonna
say something stupid and it's just going
keep leading up to that Christmas game
brother so I'm gonna see you real soon
and don't you worry the lion versus the
cheetah match Chip is going to be very
very very very very soon and I can't
wait for it
um I would say the hardest fans to play
in front of though
I think is very underrated was the
Viking Stadium skull stadium was all the
last two years when I played up there
their Stadium always has been very loud
very obnoxious actually 49er country is
pretty pretty tough too when we played
that game up there
um in the bay that was pretty tough so I
would say my top two would be the 49ers
or the Minnesota Vikings those are my
top two
teams and places where I was like man
like this is some for real stuff so
Dallas Cowboys Nation we gotta step up
we should have the most vicious the most
obnoxious the most
uh just nasty environment in the country
baby ATT Stadium we gotta turn it up
every time we got to get this thing lit
we gotta go to a whole nother level uh
people should have us in a top three top
two if not two we always number one baby
so we're gonna have to turn this up
um and you know the Dolphins got to win
but the best plays it was in the game
was that black field goal by the
Patriots uh special teams usually always
tend to Edge out victories and stuff
like that
um but this play right here was
something really special
um that was very different I don't think
we've seen something like that before uh
Belichick always has something up his
sleeve so we gotta watch out for them
and what they doing special teams and
they had you know a lot of pro bowlers
come away from their special teams so I
think we all need to take a look at what
they doing down in New England because
it's always something special on special
teams and Belichick he's just a master
at this stuff he's done it so long he's
found you know sneaks and ass to add to
his game and this was really cool to see
uh I would love to see this stuff more I
must you know I'm pretty sure bones is
going to have this on his slideshow on
Wednesday but if it's not I'm gonna have
to bring it up to him like Hey did you
see that because I think I can go do
that you know I feel like I can do
anything sometimes
um but you know all jokes aside that was
really cool to see and there was a lot
of talks about Justin fields and the
Bears lost to the Buccaneers
um that brings me to two questions is is
uh they say you know there's a enough
time for Justin to make plays and things
like that and can Justin's confidence be
restored
um we gotta remember this folks
Justin Fields walked into a program and
they're still rebuilding
um just because they got DJ Moore and
they got these uh pieces now they still
having trouble up front they're still
going through this and guys still have
to get open I don't think DJ Moore is
going to completely turn around an
organization and Justin Fields needs a
little bit more help I mean they gave
away roquan Smith who's an All-Pro
linebacker they released Robert traded
away Robert Quinn
um they didn't take Jalen Carter in the
draft they decided to go online to help
their guy but we have to remember they
can't take We cannot put this type of
weight on a young guy to say Hey you
have to change our program around
um it's just unrealistic Justin Fields
has only been there this is going into
his third year
um it's just super unrealistic uh
there's so many things that needs to be
added to that team and there's he's
going to continue to grow with it he's
super athletic he has all the tangible
his his throwing is great
um he's fast I mean we can't we can't
just say to write them off yet man
Justin Fields still needs time
um he's in the same boat as these other
guys give him time bro turn it around an
organization is very hard we everyone
cannot be Tom Brady's of the world
everyone cannot be a Joe borough of the
world and even Joe burrow
um struggled his rookie year he had a
lot more success when he got his guy
Jamar Chase back
um but we cannot just or Patrick Mahomes
but we can't just throw people in these
calendar caliber eight-tier quarterbacks
and just say hey
um we expect this guy to do this because
another team had it that's just not how
life work guys and I don't think we
should always bash guys for that
um you know there's there's
classifications and everything you know
there's always them Elite tears there's
good tears better tears there's good
tears
um and Justin Fields is on his way to be
a a very good tear he just has a lot of
time growing and he has to add some more
things around him to uh to buy in and I
think you know the effort of his
teammates need to show that too I don't
think uh some people just come into
games and expect to lose hey we might
not be good enough and sometimes that
hurts that that leadership someone on
our team is going to have to step up and
say hey guys listen who's going to be
the guy that's going to do it this week
who's going to be the guy to make the
play who's going to be the guy that
changes this game around and I think
that's uh kudos to our environment the
Cowboys is that in our defense a lot of
room we praise everyone we said who's
gonna be the guy so all right we
challenge each other every week say I'm
gonna be the guy I'm gonna be the guy
and everyone in the room has that same
mentality so it shouldn't matter who's
on the field it's something that's built
inside your organization it's built
inside your leaders it's something
that's going to have to be spoken about
um so whatever's going on in our
organization they're gonna have to face
that and get ready for that because
we're going they're going to need guys
to step up not guys that's going to go
out there and have access and trying to
collect checks they need guys that's
going to go out there and give
everything they got and say hey we're
going to win this game and we're going
to be the one to make the play and
that's what it's all about guys that's
what it's like playing National Football
League not guys that's just out there
collecting Chase I mean anybody can
collect checks but listen guys we do
this for you you we do this for the fans
we do this for you know everyone who
believed in us our families um and
sometimes it means more to some and it
shows and for me especially every time
you guys jump to ATT I'm gonna give my
all I'm a guard that I feel and I'm
gonna die trying to give you guys
everything I have because that's what I
believe in and that's what I owe to my
teammates my family and the uh Cowboys
organization because that's what it's
really about and that's what we need to
see and on the flip side the ceiling for
Baker led the boxes uh we might we might
see this uh Baker comeback
um and that's the truth about it they
upset the Vikings last week uh it was a
toss-up game between the Bears and the
bucks but we still need to see more from
Baker it could be too early but it's a
potential to rise on a comeback it's a
potential that Baker could be saying I
got my fresh start I'm a fitness system
uh he has great tangies around him with
Mike Evans Chris Godwin
um so this might be Baker's chance to
say hey guys listen I could still be a
lead player in this uh National Football
League and play good ball we saw that
from Baker sometimes a fresh start is
all you need and I'm glad to see that
from him um we should never wish the
worst or no one uh we should always wish
to success and I'm glad to see what
Baker's doing and that's big
um talking about quarterbacks last week
I did mention that Brock turdy was a top
15 quarterback and yes people are saying
oh um we want to see him play from
behind it shouldn't be overlooked
sometimes your team may be good you may
never be from behind because your team's
just that good or you're just that good
uh let's not just uh put that down just
because he's playing at a better level
than most uh Brock Brody's top 15 right
now and some young QBs I'm looking at is
uh Anthony Richardson uh Desmond Ritter
uh I thought Ritter played a great game
last week uh being the Packers um and
you know Anthony Richardson he's showing
a lot of flashes and he's looking great
uh he just got to learn to protect
himself a little bit more knowing that
this National Football League can't
always run and things like that as we
learn from guys like Cam Newton I
thought Cam Newton was dominated young
and used his legs and things like that
but the toll over time brother
um and I thought that was very cool to
hear Trevor Lawrence say to Anthony
Richardson hey you gotta learn how to
get down uh the league is a little
different
um Trevor learned it from early
experiences and giving the knowledge to
the young one um knowing that he can be
very special and that's what the game's
all about uh teaching the game to the
young guys and getting ready and
understanding that you know this is
different you know and uh AR protect
yourself brother we want to see you in
that field we want to keep seeing you
get better
um we want to see your longevity it's
not worth it throw the ball away get
down whatever it may be
um just just don't just don't risk your
career continuously run run when you
have a chance and get down don't keep
fighting
um unless that game's online brother
protect yourself and you're gonna have a
bright future ahead in this league
um
I think the top three hardest QBs
current QBs to defend is obviously uh
with number three I'm gonna have to say
Josh Allen
um Josh Allen is a top five guy
um yes he makes a lot of mistakes but
his his way to just extend plays
um and yes it turns to buy him because
he just believes he's that guy he's just
so courageous and he can just throw it
anywhere and he can make them throws and
yes we've seen him make them throws and
we see him do that but also we've seen
that bite him but the way he can extend
with his legs and he's almost trying to
run guys over and he gets excited about
it that's always scary like that's scary
like the fact that we have a six four
250 pound quarterback
um just coming out and just running
trying to run defensive linebackers over
defensive ends and even corners and say
hey I'm here and I'm flexing on you and
it can also throw in the ball uh
bazillion yards Josh we get it bro
you're freaky like come on brother I
would say he's number three uh hardest
to defend and number two I would say
Lamar Jackson
um Lamar is the most explosive QB I
think we've seen ever in the National
Football League
um I don't think no one is on his speed
level in terms of making people Miss uh
his ability to throw the ball I mean
Lamar can really do it all and he's more
exposed to Michael Vick like he's a
truly a creative player and number one
obviously is our reigning MVP are
top-notch number one quarterback he'll
probably go in the Hall of Fame right
now with the stats and accolades he have
and that's Patrick Mahomes I do not
think uh there is a better quarterback
than Patrick Holmes in the National
Football League right now and that's in
terms of people don't realize how sticky
fast he is how he could throw the ball
any which way he's dinking Duncan he can
make any type of throw if you watch on
his uh
his his show the quarterback Show on
Netflix the way he's able to torque his
body and just throw in any manner I
think that's what's scary and he knows
how to accept plays he has legs and he
can make any throw in the field and he
could throw the ball almost as good as
Josh Allen or further like come on guys
uh Patrick Mahomes is the most
I don't think we've ever seen a guy like
Patrick homes in the National Football
League in terms of everything that he
does the things that he invented and
thrown out in this league has been
absurd so far and it's always great to
see him do well uh past my guy man Pat
you are the best quarterback in the
National Football League and there's no
doubt about it and uh anybody who says
different they are obviously do not know
anything about football brother and just
keep being great and doing what you do
and before we look ahead what everyone's
talking about and that's college
football and that's Colorado okay and
the thing that I love about Colorado is
prime time is doing it the way he wants
to do it he's doing it the way he likes
to do it and he's not letting anyone
change his style and I love it bro and I
love it because anything in life uh when
you're talking about that one percent
and where you want to be at you should
always do it the way you want to do it
and you should love the way that you do
it you're the one that has to lick
yourself in the mirror and say I'm doing
it this way and I'm gonna be proud of it
whether it works or not and if it
doesn't work you adjust but if it does
work you keep freaking doing it and
Prime Time keep freaking doing it that
was a great game this past weekend
um that versus that they face their
environment seeing all uh Dwayne The
Rock Johnson seeing a sellout something
that we never seen from Colorado before
we might literally be watching
witnessing greatness of a team of
Colorado changed a whole program around
based off of one one person
um and that is something beautiful to
see to see the support that people are
given prime time seeing the love and
care and joy that he's bringing to this
organization a money that he's building
uh this university around is something
really inspiring and I think everyone
should take notice of uh everyone should
take notice of this prime time is doing
something that we have never seen before
and it's something so beautiful to see
and I think we should all appreciate
what he's doing and I think people
should follow suit
um and then also you look at the way his
son has been playing his son's been
playing at a Heisman level I don't know
if anyone expected this I know there's a
lot of hype about Travis Hunter and what
he's capable of but Shadow Sanders is
the real dude I think he's giving Kayla
Williams a run for his money uh and it's
something for her the way he was able to
knock out that two minute drive backed
up in that situation and then what he
did at OT uh the focus the dedication
that him and his dad is putting into
that University is something really
special I don't think we'll ever see as
great of his father-son duo in college
football in a very very long time uh and
I don't think people expected Shadow to
be that good uh I think people just said
hey it's Prime Time son and a lot of
people slept on him but hey I'm letting
you know now keep proving to people
wrong it's something special you're
doing what you need to do and uh we all
can't wait to continue to see watch you
guys's Journey uh over these next couple
months and hopefully see you guys in
National Playoff or college football
playoff because uh you guys have a
chance and I hope you guys make it
um one thing that really did throw me
off was that hit on Travis Hunter uh
that was so malicious and dirty uh I
thought that guy should have got ejected
uh that was something that you hate to
see in football uh if you watch this the
ball is down he let go to play the fact
that he went around his own player and
hit Travis hunter that is malicious
intent and super dirty uh this guy
doesn't deserve to be on no Football
League because at the end yes we are
competing and we want to compete the
best within each other but in the day in
college and even the NFL we need to
protect our brothers here man listen
life is way bigger past football but
this this right here is not okay Travis
Hunter uh you don't deserve that brother
you way bigger than this moment and the
one thing I respect about Travis he
tried to get back and fight and get back
in that game and that tells you a lot
about the competitor who he is who he
wants to be and where he's going in life
and Trav keep balling brother you doing
something that no one's seen at the
college level to be the efficient and as
good as you are both ways in college
football yeah you doing your thing
brother keep going
um everyone's supporting you
and eight boys down to this who do we
got this weekend Colorado Oregon uh it's
gonna be a great match is to see the
adversity they had losing Travis and uh
fighting back and still winning that
game I'm still going to take Colorado
because it's showing hey we're gonna
lose our best player hey we we are going
to go through adversity hey everything's
not going to be prayed there were so
many flags and penalties on both sides
on both teams and they still fought
through it and the better team always
wins in those type of games so hey I'm
taking Colorado keep going shoulder
Prime Time OG triple OG hey man we hey
everyone supporting you we super happy
for you and hopefully I can't even come
down to Colorado one day and check it
out because what you're building right
now is something special and tonight we
got a Monday night football games we got
Saints versus Panthers Browns versus
Steelers uh and my in my mind the way
the Saints looked if we could get a nice
dare car I'm gonna take Derek Carr
um and the Saints uh they just look real
good right now we know their defense is
always really good and the way they
played uh last week and they dominated
that defense and their back end
um is looking very special right down in
New Orleans as long as Carr can continue
to keep getting better and figuring out
that offense uh I'm gonna take the uh
Saints in that match up and then the
next matchup is the brown Steelers I'm
gonna take the Browns again you know uh
the Browns is a team even though we
might not see a mark Cooper I would
still love to see how DeSean Watson
continues to progress and you know
continues to get better
um you know Deshawn is just a guy that
we haven't seen in a while and we're
still learning the girl he's still
getting back into football but just how
good he was at the prime and premium his
career
um I'm gonna bet on them and their
defense to hold up uh you know Pickens
and the rest of their weapons especially
with uh Deontay Johnson out
um I think the Browns are gonna hold up
I think they have the better roster they
have the better team it's just about are
they going to execute the same level as
they did against the Bengals and uh it's
gonna be crucial to see how TJ watt does
uh tjy is the top five at rusher if they
can find a way to control TJ Watt and K
keep him off of uh DeShaun Watson but if
you let TJ watt ruin that game TJ watt
will ruin the game that's what he did
and uh if he had a better uh support
team last week he would have ruined that
game against the 49ers three sacks and
two Force fumbles like are we serious
bro like if TJ watt finds a way of
ruining this game he will uh it's just
going to say how good is everyone else
going to play uh and Ken the Cleveland
Browns uh slow him down and you know and
that's going to be the the epitome of it
and that's what it's all about okay when
they slow TJ watt down that can DeSean
Watson get going without Mark Cooper
with the weapons they have uh and uh
preview of next week before we wrap it
up on the edge and I hope everyone
enjoyed it uh we have
the Dallas Cowboys versus the Arizona
Cardinals we can't Overlook the Arizona
Cardinals okay they had a lead on the
Washington commanders and they had to
leave on the New York Giants they blew
both of them leads so obviously this is
a very good team and a very competitive
team uh and we should have overlooked
them uh we're gonna have to really bring
everything together be special be great
and dominate them I'm kind of similar
with Josh Hobbs back in the day y'all
know what time it is we coming we locked
in we focused don't you worry guys
Cowboy Nation we got to put on and
hopefully we get another shutout
um there's no more talking now
everything's locked in laser focused and
it's hunting season the line is ready to
hunt
um I got a new prey on my mind and it's
Josh Dobbs I'm putting them on a
bulletin board I'm throwing darts at
them I'm locked in I'm focused we coming
and it's serious with no more talking no
more playing around we coming so thank
you y'all I see y'all next week in
Arizona Dallas Cowboy Nation it don't
matter where we are where we go we need
y'all to come out and show out let's get
straight to it let's get straight to
business it's hunting time baby let's
get it and that's it for the edge I hope
y'all loved it tune in I can't wait to
see you guys and talk to you guys next
week on the hottest takes in the
National Football League and that's
right here on the edge let's get
straight to it baby thank you